ich bin da sehr fassungslos über das was
vor eigentlich gesagt hat wenn man
gerade aus dem krieg in der ukraine
kommt und gesehen hat zu was die
russische armee im stande ist wie viele
menschen dort gestorben sind dann zu
sagen
die sanktionen müssen weg oder die
sanktionen bringen nichts
das halte ich für ein paar kilos
gegenüber der ukraine
ich meine wie können wir allen ernstes
weil das wäre dann sozusagen die
alternative
weiter mit putin mit einem
kriegsverbrecher mit einem geschäfte
machen
ja vielleicht weil es eben nicht schadet
wenn wir die geschäfte nicht machen also
wir sehen das noch aktuell wir haben
durch die zum beispiel jetzt ist ja die
bundesregierung auch für ein öl embargo
alleine die debatte darüber hat den
rubel preis er hat den ölpreis massiv in
die höhe getrieben
da rollt im kreml der rubel also dann
haben die mehreinnahmen als vorher und
das was ich da wo ich darauf verwiesen
habe ich habe mir das vor kurzem selbst
mal angeguckt weil ich es gar nicht
fassen konnte also wie der rubel sich
erholt hat der ist ja eingebrochen als
der krieg begann und dann ist ein
stetiger aufstieg oder ist jetzt
deutlich stärker als vorher das heißt
wir schaden der russischen wirtschaft
oder den wwe schaden putin vor allem
auch gar nicht und wer herrscht endlich
wieder den rubel und den kurs des rubel
naja ist international toren an dieser
mk tor aber es geht natürlich auch um
die wirtschaftsstruktur und wenn man
sich dort die berichte anschaut dann
schaden die sanktionen natürlich sehr
heftig der russischen wirtschaft ja wir
wissen darf ich auch ein paar sachen
unterscheiden also ich habe gar nichts
gegen sanktionen im gegenteil die finde
ich richtig gegen oligarchen gegen leute
aus putins umfeld also wenn man da
irgendwie eine million hunderte
millionenschwere jacht beschlagnahmt und
das geld irgendwann für humanitäre
unterstützung oder wiederaufbau der
ukraine verwendet wunderbar also habe
ich nichts einzuwenden ich rede über die
energie im bus die sanktionen gegen
kohle gegen öl möglicherweise gegen gas
und da muss man ganz klar sagen es gibt
auch heute schon also selbst beim gas
russland hat pipelines nach russland hat
zwei pipelines in die türkei auch die
türkei beteiligt sich nicht an den
sanktionen und ich meine das irre was
passieren wird ist doch wenn wir zum
beispiel sagen wir kaufen kein gras mehr
bei putin denn werden die zwei pipelines
zb in die türkei voll ausgelastet die
türkei wird dann dieses gas
weiterverkaufen am ende kommt das
gleiche größe schön gas wahrscheinlich
sogar bis hin zu uns weil wir haben ja
gar kein anderes nur dass es noch viel
viel teurer wird und am ende wenn sie
auch mehr pipelines bauen beim öl ist es
ja sogar noch leichter da brauchen sie
nur tanker die sie befüllen indien freut
sich wenn sie billige russische
rohstoffe bekommen china freut sich
viele länder sind gerne bereit billige
russische energieträger zu kaufen
während hier die preise durch die decke
gehen viele menschen wirklich aktuell
verzweifelt sind weil sie nicht mehr
wissen wie sie ihre rechnungen bezahlen
sollen ihre gasrechnung ihre
stromrechnung der sprit ist höllisch
teuer und das geht immer weiter durch
die decke obwohl wir damit ja nicht
ernsthaft wenn das ein instrument wäre
den krieg zu beenden wenn jetzt sagen
wir okay wir müssen da jetzt durch dafür
kriegen wir aber dann auch innerhalb
eines überschaubaren zeitraums putin
dazu dass auf jeden fall dieser krieg
beendet wird okay da könnte man darüber
reden aber die sanktionen beenden den
krieg nicht also es gibt überhaupt keine
chance sondern wir werden so zu sagen
wir ziehen uns wir entziehen uns etwas
was unsere volkswirtschaft dringend
braucht nämlich preisgünstige in der
energieträger und daran hängt die
industrie in deutschland also das sind
100.000 industrie arbeitsplätze die
wegfallen
es werden ganze industrie branchen aus
deutschland wegziehen wenn hier die
energiekosten so hoch bleiben das ist
unser wohlstand das ist der wohlstand
von millionen menschen und ohne sinn und
verstand weil putin dann eben woanders
seine geschäfte macht was soll das also
ich verstehe es nicht also ich es hat
keine logik vorrang nicht weil die
türkei oder china möglicherweise bereit
sind
weiteres nicht möglich oder sind dazu
bereit sind weiter geschäfte mit putin
zu machen kann es ja nicht im
umkehrschluss bedeuten dass wir deshalb
sagen okay andere machen es auch
deswegen müssen wir das jetzt auch
wieder tun und natürlich ist es bei den
sabres hallo nur uns als normal das ist
also dass das ist falsch vorwagen das
ist falsch natürlich wird der russischen
wirtschaft immens geschadet zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt durch diese sanktion das ist
fakt das zweite ist wenn wir darüber
nachdenken wie dieser krieg zu beenden
ist dann
sind die sanktionen natürlich in einem
in einem zeitraum zu betrachten ist
dauert bis sozusagen dieser schaden
größer wird und bis dann auch in der
russischen bevölkerung
möglicherweise das kann man nur hoffen
ein umdenken stattfindet das ist ja auch
der sinn dieser sanktionen um zu zeigen
um zu sagen das was ihr dort tut das
sind kriegsverbrechen das ist ein
angriffskrieg den in der ukraine führt
und das sind unsere sanktionen und das
ist natürlich auch unser moralischer
anspruch aber als erstmal glaube ich
sind wir uns einig dass russland keine
lupenreine demokratie ist also um das
man zynisch zu sagen also selbst wenn
die bevölkerung und wahrscheinlich sind
viele längst der meinung also ich meine
die umfragen ich weiß nicht wie ernst
man die nehmen kann ich denke schon dass
es russland viele menschen gibt die sich
gewünscht hätten dass es diesen krieg
nie gibt aber die fragt man doch nicht
und wenn die wenn es denen schlechter
geht wenn die ärmer sind ja gut weil man
sie ernsthaft dass hat irgendeinen
einfluss auf die entscheidung im kreml
und das zweite ist eben natürlich wenn
sie sagen längerfristig jajeh
längerfristig wir planen desto besser
kann putin unter kann die russische
wirtschaft sich umstellen der zeitung
eine fraktion verhängt hätten wäre da
nicht das zeichen gewesen dass wir damit
in ordnung sind mit dem krieger ukraine
naja ich muss ja mal sagen wenn wir die
gleichen maßstäbe überall anlegen gibt
es ganz viele länder mit denen wir nicht
verhandeln dürfen ich meine herbig hat
mit einem also bückling und kinderzahl
in katar ist der vaart der vorgesprochen
katar hat sich jahrelang an dem wirklich
furchtbaren und brutalen krieg im jemen
beteiligt gemeinsam mit saudi arabien
vereinigte arabische emirate frauen auch
immer noch auch immer noch dort krieg
führen sodann im jahr in katar gilt die
scharia also weil sie vorhin von
vergewaltigung gesprochen haben was ja
wirklich ein ganz schlimmes verbrechen
ist wenn in katar eine frau vergewaltigt
wird dann kommt sie dafür ins gefängnis
die frau nicht der mann weil sie dann
eine ehebrecherin
also ein land ist das so und da gehen
wir jetzt hin und betteln dass sie uns
ihr teures flüssiggas verkaufen weil wir
das billige putin gas nicht mehr wollen
was ist da logisch und wie gesagt putin
kann sein gas ja nicht nur nach china
und in die türkei verkaufen ganz
lateinamerika wird allerdings nicht ganz
noch nicht haben ich mache die sanktion
schlecht und sagen das bringt nicht sie
sagen dass waffen nichts bringen und sie
sagen sollen die doch jetzt irgendwie
verhandeln also ein besonders ein das
klingt wahnsinnig was sie da sagen denn
ein wir wissen doch wie es jeden tag
momentan im donbass putins truppen
versuchen weitere orte einzelnen weitere
städte einzunehmen und die ukraine sich
dort verteidigt er soll sich ja auch
verteidigen aber der krieg ist da waren
uns doch einig nicht so gelaufen wie
putin sich das vorgestellt hat und
deswegen kann man davon ausgehen dass
jetzt auch die russische führung
interesse an einer lösung hat die ihr
einen gesichtswahrenden hausherr ist
also warum glauben sie das denn wenn wir
uns anschauen wie sich wie sich die
russische regierung verhalten hat ich
gebe ihnen recht die rede von wladimir
putin am neunten mal bei einem
gemeindehaus am 15 andré hatten aber
dennoch will er ja diese besetzten
gebiete mario pohl die landverbindung er
will im osten weitere gebiete die villa
sozusagen ja für sich beanspruchen und
das ist ja etwas was diego maradona muss
akzeptieren klein natürlich nicht aber
darüber muss man verhandeln im kern geht
es in diesem krieg meines erachtens
nicht um territorial gewinne es geht um
geopolitik also das ist ja von anfang an
der streitpunkt gewesen russland wollte
nicht hinnehmen dass auch die ukraine
teil der nato wird dass sie teil der
amerikanischen einflusszone wird